hi I'm Eric Voss and Game of Thrones
final episode is upon us and we're
feeling a range of emotions shock if
your monster joy and if you're a
three-eyed bush nothing at all the next
episode teaser for episode 6 gives us a
few interesting clues or what could
happen in this final hour
and how exactly Game of Thrones will
confirm or completely ignore our
long-running theories for how this will
all end and real quick before I begin
new rock stars will actually be in New
York City this Sunday hosting a special
watch party for the final episode at the
hotel Red Lion in Brooklyn we will watch
the finale together host an exclusive
live taping of our after-show and drink
and know things tickets are actually
going fast so check out the link in the
description below here we go
[Music]
okay the teaser opens in the ruins of
King's Landing Sir Thomas and John
survey the damage and by the looks of
things really none of the residents who
stayed there survived it's a ghost town
drogon swept them all like a Roomba a
deadly comprehensive fire-breathing
Roomba it's really hard to distinguish
what's rubble and what's charred human
remains visible in a window frame is a
shape that definitely looks like a
child's skeleton this aftermath is even
worse than the previous time King's
Landing was sacked when Robert Baratheon
with the help of the Lannister forces
overthrew the Mad King
during that sack in sir Jorah Mormont
who was there later described how men
became beasts killing children raping
women really the only silver lining to
that previous sack was that it could
have been a lot worse
the Mad King ordered the city to be
burned down with wildfire but Jaime
Lannister of course killed him and in
the books Jaime actually chased down the
pyromancers to kill them too before they
could detonate the wildfire caches
around the city but as we saw last
episode Daenerys completed her father's
work the sequence included shots of
those same wildfire caches blowing up
with green fire among the dragon fire
it'll be interesting to see if Jon
enters the red keep to find Danny smugly
sitting on the Iron Throne to parallel
the famous moment Ned Stark walked in on
the Kingslayer smugly sitting on the
throne after killing Daenerys his father
Tyrion also walks to the ruins similar
to how he reacted after Daenerys torched
the Lannister troops in Episode five of
last season that aftermath led to
Daenerys demanding the defeated to bend
the knee and executions for those who
wouldn't now I think we can expect an
heiress to continue to let it be fear
and keep the executions rolling Tyrion
gazes up at the red keep
not completely destroyed but in pretty
rough shape a fire continues to burn and
the Tower of the hand has collapsed as
hand to the new queen that could be a
sign of trouble for Tyrion no spoils a
victory for him and perhaps punishment
from the Queen for his betrayal he did
help his brother Jaime Lannister escaped
so that Jaime could go help Cersei
escape yeah that's treason we'll see
what happens but let's move on
[Applause]
the teaser continues with a shot of Aria
glaring at the celebrating de frackie
and unsullied troops last episode ended
with her leaving the city on horseback
but now she appears to have stuck around
more than any other character Aria
witnessed the fallout of Daenerys
cruelty on innocent civilians women
children commoners horse toys the very
same bell tower that Daenerys ignored
crumbled and collapsed on Aria Aria may
have taken the hounds advice to step
back from a revenge mission against
Cersei but after that choice the trauma
on the streets of King's Landing must
have had some impact on her Daenerys has
gotta be in arias crosshairs thank you
to war robots for sponsoring this video
war robots is an action-packed tactical
multiplayer game with six versus sixteen
battles in real time like I'm obsessed
with this game which like Game of
Thrones is all about teaming up with
badasses around the world to catch your
enemy off guard and light them up I just
love these rich 3d graphics and smooth
gameplay and if you install now you'll
get a huge starter pack with one GI
patent robot plus a unique skin for it a
full set of weapons 100 gold and 400,000
silver war robots gives you a huge
variety of futuristic robots and weapons
to best fit your playing style and there
are constant updates with new robots new
maps new game modes these developers are
always hustling to make the game even
better join me and millions of other
players worldwide and download war
robots using the link in the description
below to hit this awesome new game and
to directly support this channel okay
back to the teaser so John killing
Daenerys is certainly justified at this
point and if he does that that would in
a way fulfill the azure Ahai prophecy
that has been lingering throughout the
series quick refresher here is or Ahai
reborn or the prince / princess that was
promised is the mythological figure
prophecy to vanquish the darkness with a
flaming sword called light bringer
there are various product descriptions
of what their origin would look like and
several different indicators from the
books and the show that end up pointing
to either Jon Snow or Daenerys Targaryen
being this figure even though in the
show REO was the one to deliver the
death blow to the night king the true
darkness on the show could end up being
the human base cruelty that
Harris is now inflicting according to
legend azor Ahai plunged his sword into
his whiteness Anisa fusing the steel of
the sword with her soul and setting the
sword of blades giving him the power of
the Lord of Light so maybe on the show
if John kills Daenerys with his sword
Longclaw John could at least
metaphorically fulfill this prophecy and
in this kind of darkness as the Dothraki
and the unsullied celebrate snow drifts
down to King's Landing it's interesting
that despite the White Walkers apparent
defeat winter continues to come the
seasonal long night might still be upon
them last episode the red cape was
smashed by dragon fire the Lannister
sigil above the Iron Throne was blown in
and presumably parts of the ceiling and
walls have collapsed this falling snow
would make the red cape interior look
exactly like Daenerys his vision in the
house of the undying in season two
remember in that possible premonition
Daenerys almost touches the Iron Throne
but turns away at the last second she
goes out into the snow defying Drogo in
her unborn child Rago could that vision
have been of an afterlife for Daenerys
hinting that she will be queen of the
ashes but never actually rule the final
shot of the teaser shows Daenerys from
behind with her braids appearing more
elaborate than ever
Daenerys has kept her hair in a
traditional Dothraki Jack over the
seasons to represent her increasing
victories but last episode she released
the braid reflecting her brief failure
in loss of pride but now the braid is
back in full force reflecting her at
peak pride the symmetry of Daenerys with
her unsullied drip formation casts her
in this authoritarian light hinting that
her barbarism will continue i mentioned
the possibility of a tyrion treason
trial and execution making this the
third time tyrion would be on trial
throughout the series but this time for
a crime that he actually committed John
might also face charges he violated
Daenerys his orders to keep his true
identity a secret when he told his
sisters Sansa then leaked it to Tyrion
who leaked it to Varys who now leaked it
all over the realm
Daenerys might now be facing pressure to
step aside from enemies to the north
enemies to the east enemies to the west
in the South putting her in exactly the
same position that Cersei was also
remember last episode there was that
interesting look from grey worm as he
saw John trying to hold the troops back
during the sack of King's Landing he
gave him this cold glare
maybe that was setting up gray worms
Serbian as a witness against John
arguing that he's not truly loyal to
their cause if we are moving toward a
conflict between John and Daenerys and
they wipe each other out who does that
leave for the Iron Throne
weirdly Betty markets have been ranking
branch to end up on the throne which I
guess would be good for him now that
Daenerys has opened up the red cape to
the elements to allow some sunlight in
but remember there's also Gendry whom
Daenerys recently legitimized as a
Baratheon and Lord of storms end that
would make him a son of a recent King
give him technically a claim to the Iron
Throne but if not John who do you think
would make the best choice for ruler of
Westeros comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter a TA boss subscribed in new
rockstars and again if you live in New
York join us for our live finale watch
party and after-show this Sunday details
in the description thank you for joining
me and if brand does end up taking the
Iron Throne let's put some wheels on
that baby roll them around Westeros
cutting people with the swords as it
passes them now you know how my kind
feels when you carve initials into our
faces
[Music]